une belle fréquentation donc pour la
Foire de tour belle fréquentation aussi
chez nos voisins de Blois tout le
week-end c'est la cinquième édition du
bouchon de Blois qui a attiré curieux et
connaisseur de voitures anciennes des
centaines de véhicules exposés en ville
dont certains très originaux comme ce
premier monospace créé par Fiat en 1955
en voiture avec Hélène Chaplin
parmi la diversité des véhicules anciens
présents sur cette dernière édition du
bouchon de Blois comme beaucoup de
visiteurs nous tombons sous le charme de
cette Fiat Multipla de 1955 le premier
monospace lancé sur le marché vitesse de
pointe 90 km/h 6 places dont 3 à l'avant
un petit bijou acheté il y a un an par
Geoffrey et qui fait la fierté de son
propriétaire
[Rires]
est-ce que c'est assez rare donc les
gens ont pas l'habitude c'est vrai quand
on voit des deux chevaux on est toujours
content de voir une deux chevaux parce
que ça reste une voiture mythique mais
c'est vrai qu'on a là quand même
l'habitude on est arrivé encore à en
voir rouler alors que celle là on en
voit jamais rouler ça reste assez rare
il y a très très peu de modèles qui
roulent en France et les gens souvent
ont un peu du mal à les sortir parce que
la côte est très élevée
cette exposition de véhicules rares sur
nos routes à évidemment fait venir de
nombreux curieux férus de belles
mécaniques on est tous les deux amateurs
de voitures anciennes donc qui nous
plaît c'est de devoir de tout de tout de
tous les modèles
qu'on n'est pas arrêté juste une marque
on regarde toutes les voitures et on
aime un peu tout quoi plein de modèles
de voitures diverses années des voitures
américaines des européennes des Italiens
la Simca Chambord juste là sympa belle
couleur bien rénovée et après je
m'attendais pas à voir des véhicules
militaires
s'élancent dans le centre-ville nous
choisissons de monter à bord d'une
Américaine une Mustang cabriolet de 1970
au volant Joël importateur de voiture
américaine à Blois il a créé son
entreprise en 2018 et participe au
bouchon depuis les trois dernières
années ça permet sur une belle journée
comme ça de faire vivre un peu le
centre-ville les commerces les
restaurants de partager ma passion avec
les visiteurs de retrouver des
collectionneurs de parler ensemble de
boire un coup ensemble de faire un petit
tour en voiture ensemble une petite
balade en décapotable bien agréable sous
un beau soleil de printemps lancé en
2017 par l'association valve le bouchon
de Blois s'inscrit désormais comme l'une
des grandes animations populaires du
Blésois